hey what'd you put for nature of
relationship they only have spouse
family member and romantic yeah I just
marked romantic basically because it was
the closest to where my pen already was
okay look there is nothing romantic
about this relationship I have been very
clear about that yeah I agree with you
but we're not family members and we're
definitely not married so I'm calling
corporate
you've called corporate so much that you
have memorized their number you're gonna
need to talk first ask for extension 224
the operator hears my voice she won't
put me through yeah extension two two
four please
ha I got through I don't understand the
problem the problem Maureen is you have
boxes for eight different types of
Pacific Islander but only three for what
this relationship is well it's just for
the files it doesn't matter just check
the box and let's move on with our lives
fine
whatever this doesn't mean that you're
in love it's just saying that you're in
a relationship that entails some level
of
new closeness Maureen we're gonna need
to speak to your supervisor so is the
no Robbie Robbie you're not listening to
us let me break this down for everyone
this is strictly sex no one stays over
and we keep an even tally in terms of
orgasms actually now that I think about
it I owe you a I am well aware
from Melody of the circumstances points
to a romantic relationship dude no man
in a relationship you know things about
the other person I don't know anything
about Dina nor do I care to feelings
Mutual where did I grow up I don't know
is my father dead or alive and what is
don't care Alex guys it's just a box
actually sorry to be a fly in the
ointment but if there are absolutely no
feelings of intimacy involved it could
make things a little grayer legally yes
that's our points
well thank God we looped in TJ
so we got Robbie TJ from legal Dolores
from compliance mark from operations and
the whole team in associate relations is
everyone up to speed got it uh sorry if
I cut out I'm on a cruise ship I think
what we're coming to here is adding a
fourth box yes that's all we're asking
back on track okay so what do we label
the Box
um
oh uh like uh friends with benefits oh I
wouldn't say we're friends
yeah you know what the thing is that I
don't hate Dina I'm just more ambivalent
yeah it's almost like an apathy maybe an
apathy yeah I could go with apathy
[Music]
um
sorry that's me we're just pulling it
apart all right we have been talking and
we'd like a fourth box added labeled as
other
other we're very excited about other
Maureen
[Applause]
happy with it boom did it hey good job
yeah yeah
okay I'm gonna just go dock your pay
because you should have been working all
this time
slacker you got bird seed in your hair
shut up
you don't want any oh no I I'm all good
I I threw up a bunch of cake a little
while ago
where's the wedding
and
only talk
I just want to thank you this is better
than I ever imagined
really
yeah
uh
well well well look who I got red-handed
with your pants down an egg all over
your tiny tiny bush baby face do you
think you want some cake
you just couldn't help yourself could
you you had to make me look like an
a-hole hi Dina nobody asked you Dina I
wasn't trying to make you look bad I
just felt bad for Sandra everybody feels
bad for Sandra but I get it if this is
what I need to do to stop you from
humiliating me I'll do it I'll violate
the internet all right everybody this
isn't the real party the real party is
gonna happen Saturday morning at seven
a.m
um Saturday's actually my day off and I
used my last sick day today oh Jerry No
One's Gonna notice if you're not there
now obviously it's mandatory for you
okay do you need me to bring anything
cups would be nice not plastic though
glass drinks and probably food people
are going to want to eat at this thing
right yeah maybe empanadas
[Music]
first unless you're wearing like the
breakfast maybe
touch the ground
get out
I calm down do that stands open it gets
hurt and this is what I trained for okay
I'm gonna start killing somebody every
minute unless
unless you agree to marry me Cheyenne
hit it hey what the oh
[Music]
I had nothing to do with this yeah I
know
this is the fault of YouTube
[Music]
or do you want to walk down the aisle
your baby needs a daddy we've been
banging for a while all right I'll pay
the consequences of my actions don't try
to change me cause I'm a man of actions
yo what a show I'm calling to report a
code Green in progress I repeat code
green what's the code green I passed you
a list of codes last
I said you need to get SWAT down here
right now when are we as people Gonna
Learn we're gonna get burned we're just
waiting for our turn yo hashtag black
lives matter y'all
okay if you like what you heard and saw
I'm currently seeking representation in
all areas also I do modeling so I'm just
throwing that out there all right peace
out St Louis what
oh my bad joe
Cheyenne Tyler Lee
will you marry me
or you can be like a dick about it
oh I think he's about to shoot a hostage
I'll do what I can do anything
[Music]
[Applause]
moment of beauty
[Music]
to Cheyenne
cheers hey fiancee
oh God what parts did you hear not much
since my mom was crying a lot but I was
able to catch that we're getting married
okay I swear I'll Joanna's fault it's
fine I'm sure Parker will get a new
tooth soon and they'll forget that we
promised them a big wedding
although
that's a pretty big old bow to leave
hanging
I don't know
I've been trying not to think about my
future just because it's so up in the
air with my status and you know
everything being held but
I'm just sick of putting everything on
hold
so
yeah I well I marry you someday
I mean not that I even know if that's
something you want but I'm just it is
really
we should start talking about it
I just would have preferred we talk
about it before my mom started sending
me photos of matching white tuxes
I would never do matching white Texas by
the way